foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
Tony Stark
now you work for me
what are you building stuff
[Music]
[Music]
your eyes are red your tears three long
lost boss tears of joy I hate job
hunting yeah vacation's over welcome
home so put up the scanner with
what happened over there I had my eyes
open I want to protect the People by
putting Harm's Way
[Music]
a man with a dozen of these
can rule all the fascia
yeah I can fly see
his dog
so the upgrade is complete tell you what
throw a little hot rod red in there
[Music]
good luck keeping on
thank you
what's going on here let's face it this
is not the worst thing you've caught me
doing
there's been speculation that I'm
trading around a superhero
that's not the hero type clearly
[Music]
I've been alone for a long time
not because I want to be
but because until I solve this problem I
have to be
your target is a fugitive from the U.S
government
whole military secrets
this location snatch and grab only live
capture
taken
concerned that man's whole body is a
property of the US Army you could get as
far away from me as you can
there are aspects of my personality that
I can't control
it's very dangerous to be around me
pull back now
where you go
they want it as a weapon and if we let
it go we will never get it back so if
you're taking another crack at him I
want anything I could probably arrange
something like that you ready yeah
that's even the Plainfield
it's in me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
oh it's good to be back
the notary's here front and center I'm
sorry it's very eccentric
no
if you could make God bleed
people will cease to believe in them
shucks
[Music]
all he has to do is Syrian watch there's
a world that will consume you
our priority is to get the Iron Man
weapon turned over to the United States
of America I am Iron Man the suit and I
are one
contrary to popular believer I know
exactly what I'm doing
what
when I saw you dude the Tony Stark on
that track wow you need my resources I
want to make Iron Man look like an
antique this whole lone Gunslinger act
unnecessary you don't have to do this
alone
[Music]
I hope you're ready
[Music]
foreign
textbook narcissism
agreed
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
it's not easy to do what you did
you made my man looked like a bunch of
minimum wage Mall Cops
that's hurtful would you like to tell me
where you received your training
Afghanistan
who are you
foreign
I have sacrificed much to achieve peace
for through your arrogance and stupidity
you have opened these peaceful Realms
and innocent lives
to the horror
Devastation of War
you are a vain greedy cruel boy
you're unworthy
father
take from you
I cursed you out
please open your eyes
no this is uh where'd it come from
your ancestors
and you call it science I come from a
place where they're one in the same
his fate is in his own hands now
foreign
[Music]
just give me a chance sorry son
you're saving your life
with weapons but they are won by men
I still know when to give up do ya I
could do this all day
go let's create the greatest army in
history I should be going with you look
I know you don't think I can do this
this isn't a back Valley Steven's War
but every Army begins with one man five
tries in five different cities I can
offer you a chance he will be the first
in a new breed of super soldiers
[Music]
that wasn't so bad that was kind of
silly
more because we have the best man
[Music]
to the gates of hell
[Applause]
task won't be simple
who the hell are divorce of money
your enemy
is not what you expect
choose
what do you think
I think it works
you were made
to be ruled
in the end
[Music]
every man for himself
what do we do
we get ready
[Music]
there was an idea to bring together
a group of remarkable people
[Music]
so when we needed them
they could fight the battles but we
never could
gentlemen
what are you prepared to do
no offense but I don't play well with
others big man in a suit armor take that
away what are you uh genius billionaire
playboy philanthropist
[Music]
because we can't protect the Earth
damn sure will avenge it
[Music]
Dr Banner your work is unparalleled and
I'm a huge fan of the way you lose
control and turn into an enormous green
rage monster
thanks
[Music]
[Music]
got a lot of apologies to make
foreign
since New York
they experience things and then they're
over
I can't sleep
and when I do I have nightmares
honestly
there's a hundred people who want to
kill me I hope I can protect the one
thing I can't live without
[Music]
ladies
children
some people call me a terrorist
I consider myself a teacher
lesson number one
Heroes there is no such thing
[Music]
foreign
be the fool I always took you for
some believe that before the universe
there is nothing
they're wrong
there was darkness and it has survived
[Music]
I gave you my word I would return for
you
to face an enemy can I run into a few no
no need to one
you must be truly desperate to come to
me for help if we do nothing they will
destroy us
you even think about betraying him I'll
kill you
that was from New York I like her
Thor your bravery
will not ease your pain
your family
your world will be extinguished
running out of time
it's a very fabric of reality in between
apart
I'll find a way to save us all
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
the ones that do call him the Winter
Soldier
[Music]
it's a ghost
you'll never find him
[Music]
The Joint shield to protect people
you have to Build a Better World
sometimes means turning the old one down
that makes enemies
fast
strong
had a metal arm
[Music]
are you ready all it takes is one step
people are gonna die
I can't let that happen
Captain America needs my help
when do we start
we just did
price of freedom is high
surprise I'm willing to pay
they told me not to trust anyone
This Is How It Ends
and goes
[Music]
like you giving the orders now Captain
damn right
how do we know the good guys from the
bad guys if they're shooting at you
they're bad
I come from Earth a planet of Outlaws
my name is Peter Quill
is one other name you might know me by
Star-Lord
who was Star-Lord man legendary Outlook
guys
forget it
[Applause]
[Music]
so here we are
a Thief
two thugs
an assassin
Animaniac
but we're not gonna stand by his evil
wipes out of the Galaxy I guess we're
stuck together partners are you telling
me the fate of 12 billion people
is in the hands of these criminals oh
yeah
[Music]
I look around you know what I see losers
but life's giving us a chance to do what
something good
something bad a bit of both oh what the
hell I don't got that long a lifespan
anyway
ah
[Music]
that you're in love with me
I'm rude ain't no thing like me except
me they call themselves The Guardians of
the Galaxy
this might not be the best idea
on what kind of feelings
I was designed
to save the world
people would look to the sky and see
hope
I'll take that from them first
there's only one path to peace
there are Extinction
I tried to create a suit of armor around
the world but I created something
terrible artificial intelligence
it's called the Ultron program
I'm sick of watching people pay for our
mistakes
is it why we fight so we can end the
fight and go home
well you amazingly failed
here we all are
nothing but our wit and our will save
the world so stand and fight
no way we all get through this I got no
plans tomorrow night
I'm always picking up after you boys
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
imagine a soldier
the size of an insect
the ultimate secret weapon
you give god-like powers to everyone
it's going to be chaos so how do we stop
him I know a guy
Scott I've been watching you for a while
you're different and I believe everyone
deserves a shot at Redemption do you
absolutely my days are breaking into
places and stealing stuff are over
what do you want me to do I want you to
break into a place and steal some stuff
makes sense
are you ready to become a hero
now the suit has power
you have to learn how to control it and
are your greatest allies you're kind of
cute whoa
when you're small you have super human
strength
do you like a bullet
so you need to know how to punch you
wanna show me how to punch show me how
to punch
that's how you punch
you tried to hide your suit from me now
it's gonna blow up in your face and
Destroy everyone you care about
get out of here
think you could stop the future
you're just a thief
no a man
I know it wasn't my idea
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
this job
we try to save as many people as we can
[Music]
sometimes that doesn't mean everybody
but you don't give up
[Music]
New York
Washington DC
jacobia
okay that's enough Captain people are
afraid
that's why I'm here
we need to be put in check
whatever form that takes on game
I'm sorry Tony if I see a situation
pointed South I can't ignore it
sometimes I wish I could
sometimes I want to punch you in your
perfect teeth
I know we're not perfect
the safest hands are still around
[Music]
what's wrong about you
the whole world was wrong about you
they're coming for you
I'm not the one that needs to wash their
back
this doesn't have to end in a fight Tony
you just started a war
[Music]
sit down final warning
I could do this all day
all right I've run out of patience
Andrews
hey everyone
foreign
you think you know how the world works
what if I told you
the reality you know is one of many
this doesn't make any sense not
everything does
not everything has to
[Music]
through the Mystic Arts we harness
energy and shape reality
we travel great distances
in an instant
how do I get from here to there how did
you become a doctor study and practice
your disability
there's a strength to him but is he
ready
[Music]
careful which paths you travel
Downstream stronger man than you have
left away
I am dead
in pain
will die protecting this world
hear this there is no other way
I spent so many years
hearing through time
thank you
looking
for you
[Music]
now watch this my mantra
the Wi-Fi password
we're not Savages
[Music]
hope you're ready it'll be here any
minute
is that a rifle you don't know what a
rifle looks like
both doing guns now I just didn't know
that
oh that's intense
I see it within you
fear jealousy
betrayal this is our duty to cleanse the
universe of this weakness you know they
told me you people were conceited
douchebags but that isn't true at all
dude I'm using my wrong eyes on
[Music]
[Applause]
so we're saving the Galaxy again yep
awesome we're really gonna be able to
jack up our prices for two-time Galaxy
savers
[Music]
sure
[Applause]
yeah sometimes the thing you're
searching for your whole life is right
there by your side all alone you're
right
do is yell at each other you're not
friends
no we're family
oh so maybe her
[Music]
after all these years I've Found You
and who the hell are you
I'm your dad Peter
[Music]
this is my chance to prove myself
[Music]
what's up guys wait a minute you guys on
the real Avengers I can tell Hulk gives
it away
oh that was awesome
[Music]
so where's the new top no you've seen
that before never with that skirt it's
probably stop staring before he gets
creepy though
too late
you guys are losers
so to become an Avenger are there like
trials or an interview just don't do
anything I would do and definitely don't
do anything I wouldn't do
there's a little gray area in there and
that's where you operate oh all right
that's not a hug I'm just grabbing the
top for you all right kid good luck out
there
listen I know school sucks Peter you're
still with us uh yeah yeah I know you
want to save the world but
you're not ready yet
you're the Spider-Man no I'm not I'm not
this is just a costume this is from the
ceiling
stay close to the ground
stay out of trouble
forget the flying monster guy there are
people who handle this sort of thing
treating me like a kid all the time but
you are a kid this is my chance to prove
myself
here what is going on with you I'm
really sorry I'm so busy I'm slammed
don't mess with me because I will kill
you and everybody you love
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
how did this happen
well it's a long story
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's Main Event time
[Music]
incredible
[Applause]
we know each other he's a friend from
work
[Music]
I have seen God's fly I've seen men
build weapons that I couldn't even
imagine uh-huh I've seen aliens drop
from the sky yeah but I have never seen
anything like this how much more are you
hiding
[Music]
we are home
[Music]
my son it is your time show me my
respective
you get to decide what kind of king you
are going to be
don't freeze I never freeze
[Music]
the revolution will not be televised
[Music]
show me my respect
and Bow Down
I waited my entire life for this
the World's Gonna Start Over
imma burn it off
what happens now
determines what happens
to the rest of the world
you will not be able to stay home
[Music]
foreign
there was an idea
bring together
a group of remarkable people
to see if we could become something more
[Music]
so when they needed us
we could fight the battles
that they never could
[Music]
[Music]
and time
you will know what it's like to lose
you can feel so desperately that you're
right yet to fail all the same
regret it
run from it
Destiny still arrives
[Music]
Evacuate the city
engage all defenses
and get this man a shield
foreign
[Music]
isn't something one considers when
balancing the universe
but this
does put a smile on my face
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
the hell are you guys
[Music]
so how long have you been Ant-Man again
no uh I just sort of happened
I wish I could fight bad guys like you
[Music]
I seem to mess it up almost every time
[Applause]
maybe you just need someone watching
your back
like a partner
[Music]
Dr Pam I actually heard what happened to
you you open up the quantum realm that's
when this crazy creepy goals to like
walks through walls and stuff stole your
Tech
and now she wants to take over the world
or whatever
who would have believed that in your
hour of need you would turn to us happy
because we robbed you do you remember
Follow My Lead
[Music]
she seems
more intense
[Music]
you go low I'll go high I have wings why
would I go low
[Music]
hey what'd I miss we were just tiny
[Music]
project called Goliath how big did you
get my record 21 feet you
65 feet 65.
if you two are fresh comparing sizes 65.
[Music]
foreign
language
I know a renegade Soldier when I see one
never occurred to me that one might come
from above
space Invasion
big car chase
truth be told I was ready to hang it up
until I met you today
[Music]
so you're not from around here it's hard
to explain
I keep having these memories I see
flashes
I think I had a life here
[Music]
but I can't tell if it's real
we have no idea what threats are out
there
we can't do this alone
we need you
I'm not what you think I am
foreign
[Music]
you find this recording
don't feel bad about this
part of the journey is the end
just for the record Being adrift in
space with zero promise of rescue is
more fun than it sounds
food and water ran out four days ago
Oxygen's gonna run out tomorrow morning
I mean it
when I drift off I will dream about you
it's always you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Thanos did exactly what he said he was
going to do
he wiped out
fifty percent of all living creatures
we lost all of us
we lost friends he lost family
we lost part of ourselves
this is the fight of Our Lives
it's gonna work Steve
I know it is
because I don't know what I'm gonna do
if it doesn't
hi uh is anyone home this is Scott Lang
we met a few years ago at the airport in
Germany that got really big is this an
old message hey man hey man I know you
know I know you know that that's the
front door that's me Can you buzz me in
thank you Spiderman
that was so good hey sorry I'm late
happy you look nice thank you you too
thank you new dress yes it is how'd you
know
what just happened
[Music]
going to Europe it's a school trip
did you get your passport Peter Parker
here to pick up a passport please mini
toothpaste pack your suit
I just want to go on my trip with my
friends Europe doesn't really need a
friendly neighborhood Spiderman
[Music]
you look really pretty and therefore I
have value
I'm messing with you
you look pretty too I just want to spend
some time with MJ I think she really
likes me dude it reminds me when I first
fell in love I had just finished my
phone call before
so nice to finally meet you Spiderman
you're Nick Fury put some clothes on
let's go for a ride is she gonna be okay
like that
might want to turn him over so he
doesn't swallow his tongue
I think Nick Fury just hijacked her
summer vacation
but we have a job to do
are you going to step up or not
you're all alone
friends are in trouble
what are you gonna do about it
you don't want any part of this
who is that guy he's like Iron Man and
Thor rolled into one he's not a
Spiderman what is it with you in
Spider-Man what he looks out for the
neighbor it has a dope suit and I really
respect him what's up dickwad
[Music]
so what's a single girl like you doing
rattling around this big howl well I
assure you I'm married to a man a human
one
[Music]
we are an unusual couple
oh I don't think that was ever in
question
I just don't know what to expect
howdy neighbors hey buddy
what's up who are you I don't know
I think something's wrong here
this is our home the next fight for it
[Music]
well I think we handled that well
the legacy of that Shield is
complicated
[Music]
the world
it's upside down
people need something to get behind
they need the symbol
so what's our plan
so no plan
great
foreign
[Music]
what's going on in that cyborg brain of
yours you don't want to know oh yeah I
can see it working gears turning oh
they're malfunctioning they're on fire
god I hate you
I know what this place is
foreign
keepers have built quite the circus
and I see the clowns are playing their
parts to perfection
big metaphor guy I love it makes you
sound super smart I am smart I know okay
okay
please time to verify this is everything
you've ever said
this is absurd
sign this too
[Music]
we protect
proper flow of time
you picked up the Tesseract breaking
reality
I want you to help us fix it
why me I need your unique low-key
perspective
do I get a weapon yeah
foreign
luckily he believes in himself enough
for the both of us
why
it is adorable that you think you could
possibly
manipulate me
I'm 10 steps ahead of you
you're not big on trust are you
you can't trust me okay I've studied
almost every moment of your entire life
you've literally stabbed people in the
back like 50 times
why never do it again
I used to have nothing
foreign
[Music]
I heard you had to leave in a hurry
it's never easy these days
so what are you going to do
I've lived a lot of lives but I'm done
running from my past
and now you're out there I know you know
I'm out here
so we're going to talk like grown-ups
is that what we are
it's good to see you too says
what brings you home
we have unfinished business
we have to go back to where it all
started
lucky us
one thing's for sure it's gonna be a
hell of a reunion
[Music]
I'm stupid
together again
you got that
[Music]
foreign
I gave you 10 years to live your life
and where did that get you
you walked in my shadow
I trained you
to the most dangerous people in the
world
couldn't kill you
son
it's time for you to take your place by
my side
[Music]
that's not gonna happen
[ __ ]
[Applause]
you really are
[Applause]
who are you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh God everybody
we make a good team
[Music]
[Music]
you don't
know me anymore it's beautiful
listener
we have watched
unguided
we have helped them progress
[Music]
and seen them
accomplish wonders
throughout the years we have never
interfered
until
now
[Music]
ended when you said
foreign
Rogers and Iron Man are both gone who do
you think is going to lead the Avengers
I could leave them
[Music]
this is the first Christmas we've had
together
in years I love you guys
I'm making up for some last time
the past has caught up with me
should we be worried no no it's nothing
I'll Be Home for Christmas
promise
[Music]
when I wore this suit I made a whole lot
of enemies
you're a Hawkeye who the hell are you
some people have actually called me
the world's greatest Archer
are you one of those people it's the
most wonderful hey babe I should be back
in a day or two hang on a second
[Music]
more complicated
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
ever since I got bit by that spider
only had one week
where my life has felt normal that was
when you found out
[Music]
when you botched that spell where you
wanted everyone to forget the Peter
Parker Spider-Man
we started getting some visitors
[Applause]
from every universe
foreign
ER
I'm sorry what was your name again Dr
Otto Octavius
[Laughter]
wait no seriously what's your actual
name
there are others out there we need to
send them back
so Scooby-Doo this crap you know if all
this is kind of your mess I know a
couple magic words myself starting with
the word please
please Scooby-Doo this crap
flying out into the darkness
fight ghosts what do you mean they all
die fighting Spiderman it's their fate
I'm sorry kid
yeah me too don't
look there has to be another way where
is it they're a danger to our universe
you know how to take this away from me
you're struggling
damn everything you want while the world
tries to make you choose
my fault I can't save everyone
[Applause]
what's happening they're starting to
come through
and I can't stop them
December 17th exclusively in movie
theaters tickets on sale November 29th
spider Monday
[Music]
hello and welcome to staying awake I'm a
sleeping disorder
I can't tell the difference between my
waking eyes and dreams hello and welcome
[Music]
I'm losing it
we'll catch you all your brother useless
TV Stephen
[Music]
I can't tell the difference
between my eyes
that's the contact lens
hope you find it thanks
yeah oh my God you're alive what's wrong
with you mark why did you call me Mark
that must be very difficult
the voice in your head
shut up there's chaos in here
[Music]
embrace the chaos
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
it was the only way
but I never
meant for any of this this to happen
[Music]
Wanda
foreign
I made mistakes and people were hurt I'm
not here to talk about Westview then
what are you here for I need your help
it's what what do you know about the
Multiverse
[Music]
I'm sorry Stephen
I hope you understand
the greatest threat
to our universe
is you
things just got out of hand
[Music]
[Music]
okay so first off I just want to say I
get it you get what
High School Kamala Kamala another
adventure shirt cute she thinks I'm some
kind of weirdo you are a weirdo boys
excuse me yeah you're kind of want my
shirt sorry
but you're staring out the window in
your little fantasy land
[Applause]
come on hey already really come on like
two I have to figure out my whole future
before launchers
[Music]
maybe they're right I spend too much
time
and Fantasyland
that is not you
it's not really the brown girls from
Jersey City to save the world
that's the fantasy too
something happen to you no why did you
hear something come on
[Music]
you feel like God's neck
I always thought I wanted this kind of
life
but I never imagined any of this do you
know what you are
[Music]
[Music]
kids it's a popcorn now let me tell you
the story of the space Viking Thor
odenson he was no ordinary man he was a
God
after seeding planet Earth for the 500th
time Thor set off on a New Journey well
he got in shape he went from dead board
the cardboard
and after all that he reclaimed his
title
as the one and only four
oh spoke too soon
Jane
[Music]
the old ex-girlfriend
what's a family three four years eight
years seven months and six days give or
take
my uh sensing feelings
yeah yeah right
the only ones who Gods care about
is themselves
is My Vow
oh God shall die
I was gonna say I was very very
impressive what you did back there
[Music]
this is my first bad guy
[Music]
you never forget you first
[Music]
kill
because I have something worth fighting
for
foreign
damn it
can we help them and eventually grape
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I am blue
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
control no overwhelming feelings of Rage
no a normal amount of rage you do revert
back to Gen 4 when you sleep was the air
horn really necessary for comedy
absolutely
this is a multi-year journey you're
about to embark on
yeah who's your best friend Nikki
spandex spandex is your best friend
being a Hulk asks for balance
you have so much more to learn
[Music]
if you want to go back to life as a
lawyer I I respect that
he doesn't mean that
foreign
more eccentric superhumans are coming
out of the woodwork
we are going to launch a division for
them and I want the She-Hulk to be the
invasive Jennifer Wallace
Namaste I have a serious conflict of
interest this man tried to kill my
cousin Bruce yeah that's quite all right
oh
people only care because I'm
representing Emile bonski I think they
care because they're like hey that
girl's green
Jen do your thing good I really like
this outfit
I'm not proud of this
Walters we answer to a higher power our
universe is on the edge of a precipice I
am a lawyer who do things by the book
The Book of Ashanti no the book of
American laws
whether you like it or not you're now a
superhero let's do this
you know that friend you had in high
school
it's way cooler than you were attractive
got all the attention from everyone
[Music]
no
I think I'm jealous is that what I'm
feeling
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
me know what you whisper
[Music]
ing
show them
Who We Are
[Music]
[Music]
I used to ask myself a lot of questions
Scott you're at ex-con
how are you an Avenger that doesn't make
sense
but everywhere I go people tell me the
same thing
thank you
[Music]
it's like a satellite for deep space but
Quanah wait wait a minute you're sending
a signal down to the quantum Realm
turn it off
now
[Music]
[Music]
my hair
[Music]
it's a secret Universe beneath ours
what are you so afraid of
there's something I never told you
[Music]
it isn't what you think
[Music]
[Music]
I can get you home
and give you more time
if you help me
so
What's it gonna be
Ant-Man
[Music]
I just saw on the calendar that right
now on Earth it's almost Christmas time
we don't have time for trivialities like
Christmas but Peter's so sad about
Gamora being gone
we go to Earth they're a really
wonderful Christmas gift
[Music]
something special you will never forget
what about someone special
we are looking for the legendary Kevin
Bacon we're looking for the legendary
Kevin Bacon
I think maybe you didn't hear you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
you've been avoiding Earth I have called
for your help plenty of other times and
you've been pretty content to let those
calls go straight to voicemail
different
how much do you know about your security
detail
what do you mean how much do I know
about them
thank you
Fury
we gotta be very careful now
you're in no shape for this fight that
lies before us
[Music]
this is just the beginning this is my
War alone and I'm the last person
standing between them and what they
really want
and what is that
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this Halloween you can't escape the
shock the terror of
werewolf by night tonight it is every
Hunter for themselves good luck I'll be
rotting for you
but one of you is a monster
masquerading as one of our own
I can't wait to find out what breed of
evil you are
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you